[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
ich war gerade einkaufen habe noch eine
kiste im auto und werde jetzt kurz meine
einkäufe verräumen viele von euch fragen
schon immer machen einem
hauswirtschaftsraum heute ist es soweit
heute zeigen euch ich habe ja schon
meinen waschraum gezeigt er ist bei uns
oben im obergeschoss und der
hauswirtschaftsraum der ist bei uns hier
unten
mir war nämlich beim hausbau ganz
wichtig dass unser haus weltraum direkt
im erdgeschoss ist und zwar direkt neben
der garage
ich kenne es so aus amerikanischen
filmen dass man praktisch mit dem auto
in die garage reinfährt die einkäufe und
vorräte raus räumt und dann direkt im
anschluss in die vorratskammer kommt und
aus der vorratskammer dann in die küche
kommt
ich meine wer aber trotzdem eine normale
hauseingangstür also nach vorne wo
praktisch gäste eben klingen können oder
wir rein laufen wenn wir eben nicht mehr
im auto unterwegs sind so wäre auch ganz
oft aber wenn ich dann einkaufen wenn
dann möchte ich echt die kürzesten wege
also haben wir unser haus so konzipiert
dass es das haus der kurzen wege ist und
das war sozusagen der grundriss also die
garage in der mitte auf der linken seite
dann das studio wo wir eben arbeiten und
auf der rechten seite dann eben unser
vorratsraum und die anschließend die
küche und diesen grundriss habe ich
sozusagen murat bruder geändert und er
hat daraufhin das komplette haus drum
herum gebaut also wohnzimmer büros
toiletten und das obergeschoss also der
grundstein war wirklich der
hauswirtschaftsraum mit der küche den
zeige ich euch jetzt und wollen noch
kurz meine andere einkaufs kiste und
dann geht ihr einfach mit
[Musik]
hartz iv
wer mit ihr das system von schiller
schule baut nicht nur küchen sondern
eben auch träume aus wirtschaftsräume
easy and clean heißen die und da kann
man sich wirklich alles wunderbar am
zusammenstellen lassen und planen und es
ist einfach super funktional und
praktisch und die gibt es auch in jedem
küchen fachgeschäft also da können wir
gerne mal schauen hier vorne haben wir
auch direkt schon die tür und bei uns
ist es so werben die türen ein bisschen
anders herum geplant normalerweise
platten an die tür so dass wenn man
reingeht die tür sich nach innen öffnet
einen kleinen nachteil leben mit dem
verstauen mit dem schrecken hinten dran
aber man hat den vorteil wenn man mit
schweren kisten ankommt kann man die tür
einfach aufdrücken und reinlaufen wir
uns aber andersrum gemacht denn bei uns
ist der gang oft von hier nach drüben
ins studio das heißt ich gehe morgens
immer schwer bepackt ins studio rüber
habe hier meine kissen und kann dann
hier einfach die türen aufdrücken und
drüber laufen also wenn man gebaut und
sich den hauswirtschaftsraum eben an die
garage macht kann man das bedenken und
ja wir haben es wie gesagt andersrum
gemacht ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal einmal komplett durch ich
zeige euch die schränke zeigt was wir so
beachtet haben bei der planung und was
ganz ganz wichtig ist dass ein
hauswirtschaftsraum immer dunkel und
kühl ist unser hauswirtschaftsraum hier
das ging hat weil wir neu gebaut haben
wenn ihr nicht gerade neu baut oder
gerade gar nicht baut dann funktioniert
es vielleicht nicht aber wenn ihr könnt
dann denk dran wenn ich hier auf der
seite die nordseite das heißt da kommt
nie eine direkte sonneneinstrahlung rein
und wir haben hier einfach nur fenster
drin zum belüften aber auch für ein
bisschen licht natürlich und es sind
aber nur so halb hohe fenster damit ich
hier unten zum einen mehr stauraum habe
aber zum anderen der raum eben auch
nicht zu hell wird das heißt dieser raum
ist immer schön dunkel kühl und trocken
und das ist ganz wichtig damit eure
lebensmittel eben auch nicht kaputt
gehen
[Musik]
die zwei ersten schränke hier die haben
nicht mit lebensmitteln zu tun sondern
sind eher so meine putts schränke also
hier auf der seite habe ich einfach so
einen kleinen organizer das in die bütt
sachen drauf ein paar putztücher unten
und tritt damit ich eben auch an die
oberen schränkt gekommen hier noch unser
schlauch von der staubsauger anlage und
hier oben habe ich die reinigungsmittel
und was immer ganz wichtig ist was man
echt beachten muss reinigungsmittel
immer oben lagern damit die kinder nicht
drankommen kinder und haustiere vor
allem da unten habe ich nur
destilliertes wasser also das ist jetzt
nicht so schlimm würde ich normalerweise
auch oben lagern dem trinken darf man
das ja auch nicht aber wie gesagt da
geht auch jetzt keiner von uns dran
ich habe mich einfach an der seite alles
schön organisiert mit putztüchern unten
und oben einfach alles beschriftet mit
dem etikett ihr gerät damit auch david
weiss und jeder der hier einfach im haus
ist wohl die reinigungsmittel sind
deswegen wird hier alles beschriftet da
oben habe ich eher so meine fenster
putzen hier noch den boden reiniger
regenschirme für draußen und was ich
hier oben drin hab das ist eigentlich so
ein bisschen deko für draußen oder auch
fürs wohnzimmer also ich hab dann im
winter zum beispiel auch meine outdoor
deko und jetzt halt so sachen drin wir
blumentöpfe die ich einfach so im alltag
wenn ich brauche aber irgendwie braucht
man dann doch immer ein stauraum dafür
und es lag ich einfach da oben weil ich
da wirklich nur für alle drei monate mal
dran muss und deswegen brauchen wir
unten nicht den platz voll machen damit
sie haben wir dann so angeschrägte böden
und die sind wirklich perfekt für
wasserkisten also da kommt man dann
super dran man muss nicht extra was
aufmachen und hat wirklich alles schön
griffbereit und ich finde sie trotzdem
ordentlich aus und da kann auch ich als
vielleicht nicht so ganz starke frau
trotzdem die kiste neben runterlassen
oder auch wieder rein lupfen ob ihr
einloggen ist echt schon 1 23
[Gelächter]
ich kann das auch erleiden und hier oben
habe ich platz für meine einkaufskörbe
und einkaufslisten und damit nicht alles
offen ist haben wir auch hier noch mal
platz für getränke war einfach platz
unter mexiko lieber mehr getränke wer
lieber mehr auf vorrat als zu wenig und
hier oben die schränke die sind auch
alle voll mich alle aber fast alle also
da habe ich sowieso zeug halt drin was
man immer so nicht wirklich braucht aber
man hat trotzdem und dann ist es halt da
oben verstaut aber ich muss echt sagen
ich bin der totale aus mister als ich
bin hier bestimmt jeden monat und mister
immer sachen aus alles was ich in den
drei monaten nicht gebraucht habe landet
da oben und was ich dann nicht brauche
landes einfach bei anderen menschen ja
was haben wir hier noch das ist im
prinzip eigentlich eher so ein weinregal
also hier kann man wirklich ganz schön
weinflaschen verstauen wenn wir jetzt
auch getränke drin da oben tabletts und
hier unten einfach platz für meine
kräuter die ich selber trockne wenn man
wirklich einen großen garten und ich
habe wirklich immer ganz viele kräuter
im sommer
und da ich dann immer mit dem automaten
den zeige ich euch gleich und verpackt
an alles hier und wenn ich noch mehr
haben dann kann ich das ja auch in die
oberen schränke einräumen denn
getrocknete kräuter sind fünf jahre
haltbar
das heißt da könnt ihr euch wirklich
einen riesen vorrat anlegen und die
werden einfach nicht schlecht hier unten
habe ich dann noch solche körbe für
zwiebeln zum beispiel oder auch für
kartoffeln
die habe ich dann da unten drin ich habe
mir noch geschlossene schränke
denn ich finde man muss nicht alles
offen lagern und das meiste soll man ja
sowieso luftdicht
lichtgeschützt lagern und hier oben habe
ich einfach dinge drin wie medikamente
zum beispiel wo einfach kinder jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt dran kommen sollten
und gerade medikamente da weiß ich dass
viele die im badezimmer lagern aber das
badezimmer ist echter falsche platz
dafür denn dort ist es einfach zu feucht
und zu warm und hier in seinem
hauswirtschaftsraum wenn wir auch nie
eine heizung an
wir haben zwar die leitungen verlegt am
boden weil wir nicht wussten weil später
nach wissen ist schwierig aber wir haben
sie mir an und haben auch hier die
fenster immer offen und eine
belüftungsanlage zum entfeuchten und zum
belüften und daher sind auch medikamente
hier eigentlich immer ganz gut
aufgehoben
und wirklich immer schön weit oben dass
kinder nicht drankommen
was ich hier dann auch noch habe sind
einfach konserven zum beispiel die
lassen sich ja auch wirklich wunderbar
richtig gut und richtig lange aufheben
und die habe ich dann einfach sortiert
oliven hier so ein bisschen tomatenmark
und paprika markt tomaten aus der dose
alles was wir einfach häufig konsumieren
haben wir hier mit drin und ich finds
gerade in so schränken ganz praktisch
wenn ihr wirklich auszüge nehmt also
wirklich schubladen
denn wenn ihr jetzt nur diese
regalbretter habt dann ist es immer ganz
schwierig da ganz nach hinten ran zu
kommen und hier könnt ihr die schubladen
komplett ausziehen
die haben wir auch so eine glas seite
das heißt obwohl die schublade mir
eigentlich auch schon zu hoch ist komme
ich eben so ganz gut dran und sie auch
seitlich ganz gut rein
und vor allem haben sie einfach
verschiedene höhen das heißt hier oben
könnte ich jetzt noch habe ich ja noch
luftig könnte entweder noch im boden
einbauen
aber ich hab mir gedacht ich lass das
jetzt einfach mal ich brauche den platz
nicht und kann hier große sachen
verstauen mittelgroße sachen und eben
auch schöne flache sachen
[Musik]
sie hatten wir jetzt recht tiefe
schränke einfach für den optimalen
stauraum und für viel stauraum und hier
mussten wir jetzt aber schmalere
schränkchen nehmen weil hier eben direkt
der durchgang ist also die tür ist und
deswegen haben wir hier diese schmalen
schränke und dazwischen einfach so ein
apotheker schrank und das ist echt
perfekt weil ich hier den auszug habt
und kann so schmale und grohe sachen wie
eben flaschen oder auch mehl oder andere
lebensmittel einfach optimal verstauen
kann man kommt von beiden seiten gut
dran kann schön durch gucken und hat
alles schöne im überblick und der
überblick ist auch eigentlich das
wichtigste was man in so einem
hauswirtschaftsraum haben sollte denn
ich werde auch gleich meine einkäufe
verräumen dass die da nicht rum stehen
denn es ist einfach so wie im
hauswirtschaftsraum keinen überblick
über ihre lebensmittel habt dann werden
sie einfach schlecht weil ihr nicht mehr
wisst was ihr denn alles hat deswegen
alles schön durch strukturieren und
durch sortieren vielleicht auch
etikettieren muss nicht sein
bei mir schon und dann habt ihr einfach
den vorteil dass nicht schlecht wird
neue lebensmittel kommen immer nach
hinten und die alten lebensmittel nach
vorne und ich finde es immer ganz
optimal gerade wenn ihr auch so große
konsumenten seit wie ich viel backt und
viel kocht dass ihr wirklich immer in
einer reihe praktisch eine zutat habt
wenn es natürlich geht vom platz her und
dann eben einfach den überblick habe ich
habe zu einer reihe zucker butter zu
können würfelzucker usw
und als wir in unserer alten wohnung
waren hatten wir auch nur einen
vorratsschrank und es war wirklich der
schrank der war ungefähr so groß von
meter auf 1 meter 50 vielleicht in der
höhe und ich hatte da auch regalbretter
drin und hatte da auch immer schön
vorrat und da hatte ich zusammen
praktisch so dass ich dann vorne so zwei
zucker hatte hinten dran zweimal aber
ich wusste immer auf den ersten blick
was ich da habe und was fehlt und das
ist eigentlich schon wichtig ja ich habe
ich jetzt mehr diese offenen regalen
das sind lebensmittel die ich wirklich
ganz häufig brauche wie mehl und zucker
und kakao gaga oder auch mein vanille
extrakt hier vorne die milch wo auch die
kinder ganz gut dran kommen gerade fürs
frühstück fürs müsli und es sind dinge
die wollte ich dann gar nicht hinter
verschlossenen türen haben weil es halt
auch wieder ein arbeitsschritt mehr ist
im schrank aufzumachen die schublade zu
öffnen und hier kommt man einfach aus
der küche her freut sich ein päckli mail
und ist gleich wieder zurück in der
kirche ja was ich hier noch habe sind
einfach schubladen darunter das sind
auch so organisations sachen wie
etiketten oder stifte zahnstocher
einfach so flache dinge oder pflaster
sie ein verbandskasten oder auch so
bisher notfall notfallhilfe wieso
desinfektionsspray verwunden
da kommt man immer schnell dran und da
unten habe ich im prinzip nur noch platz
für so sperrige sachen wie brot stoßen
oder einfach kuchen dosen so jetzt freu
mich kurz meine lebensmittel sonst sind
sie nicht richtig gelagert
also der einkauf heute war von 1
wocheneinkauf ja ich war unterwegs und
wusste auch nicht ich hab ich alles da
hat oder nicht
keine einkaufsliste geführt ich habe ich
das ganze ein bisschen unterteilt in
oben habe ich eben wie gesagt die
tomaten produkte und für herzhaftes und
unwert die süßen sachen zum backen also
so eingelegtes obst und es hält sich
halt echt lange und wenn ich dann mal
was backen will und kein frisches obst
oder gefrorenes obst oder einfach lust
auf mandarin aus der dose hab dann nehme
ich die und das ist echt immer gut
und dann habe ich hier drüben und so
meine nudel vorräte und nein ich bin
nicht der nudel hamster einkäufer ich
war nicht dafür verantwortlich dass die
nudel leer war
wir haben einfach immer nur da und ich
steig auch momentan muss ich sagen auch
vollkornnudeln über weil ich die echt
lecker sind und sind einfach bisschen
gesünder und hat mehr nudeln ist es auch
so die haben zwar auch in
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum aber es wird da
auch gerade diskutiert ob man das nicht
einfach streicht der nudeln gerade wenn
sie aus hartweizengrieß sind und ohne ei
sind sind eigentlich fast ewig haltbar
also 20 30 jahre locker die können echt
nicht schlecht werden und deswegen
haltet sie einfach oder lagert sie
einfach trocken und kühl und dann
passiert da echt nichts und dann habt
ihr immer was dort zum essen ich will
nur eins sozusagen dieses video ist
nicht gesponsert von keinem hersteller
den ihr hier
in diesem video seht also ist es
wirklich einfach nur weil ihr nach
gefragt habt keiner dieser hersteller
oder dieser möbel oder egal was ist
sponsor dieses videos okay weil es
natürlich jetzt alles abkleben müssen
ich meine das hat auch nicht sinn der
sache
ich hab's halt eingekauft was habe ich
noch
kühlung habe ich nur das hier und hier
haben wir haben einen kühlschrank also
ich zeige mich auch gleich den durchgang
zur küche wir haben in der küche sondern
etwas kleineren kühlschrank und hier
einfach noch mal im kühlschrank für
vorräte weil ja der kühlschrank drin
reicht einfach nicht und ich habe ich
dann auch mal so was wie eine
angeschnittene wassermelone weil es im
anderen kühlschrank nicht ausreicht noch
einen gefrierschrank und die größten
vorräte habe ich eigentlich immer vorne
weil wir einfach viel für euch kochen
und backen für die videos und deswegen
habe ich meister in der großen küche im
studio aber hier auch immer so ganz
gesunden vorrat für unter der woche und
das wochenende mit denen lebe ich auch
weil er einfach nur schön ist und dieser
wechsel front hat ja da kann man die
farbe wechseln was ich auch immer gern
da hat sind so trockene brote sowas wie
knäckebrot weil sowas einfach auch super
lange haltbar ist und wenn wir dann
einfach mal kein frisches brot da haben
kann ich das hier lagern genauso wie so
totti as die habe ich auch gern da und
hier habe ich zeige euch glaube ich
jetzt so direkt einfach die schubladen
hier habe ich auch schubladen systeme
auf der seite und eine schöne
arbeitsplatte auf der arbeitsplatte kann
ich nämlich zum einen meine
einkaufslisten abstellen und eben
versäumen
aber ich kann auch daran arbeiten das
zeige ich euch gleich und hier in den
schubladen
hier habe ich dann so meine folien das
klebe waren das habe ich gestern gesagt
mein gott ich habe vergessen dass ich
das hier hatte ein klebeband oder hier
auch bienenwachs tücher zum abdecken und
darunter dann in der zwischen schublade
das sozusagen einfach nochmal backpapier
vorräte und wie gesagt das trockene brot
und darunter habe ich dann so eine
schublade für reis und hülsenfrüchte
also linsen kichererbsen trockene bulgur
ja so die sachen noch ein paar gewürze
eingekauft und hat so was wie salz zum
beispiel ist einfach auf ewig haltbar
und ich finde gerade salz sollte auch
kein mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum haben ich
meine ich habe hier ein reines und
raffiniertes steinsalz aus dem
urzeitlichen zechstein meer und hat das
ding 1 haben
doch es hat es hatten will das hat mir
das haltbarkeitsdatum aber gerade bei
salz verstehe ich nicht meine es war
hunderte millionen von jahren auf einem
gebirge wird dann einfach da abgeerntet
und jetzt kann das als froh sein dass
ich es gekauft habt damit es nicht
schlecht wird sozusagen aber es ist
einfach salz könnt ihr immer benutzen
also es wird nicht schlecht hauptsache
er lagert trocken hier oben habe ich
auch so ein bisschen meine gewürz pakete
verpackt kurkuma habe ich noch mal
mitgenommen weil wir ganz oft kurkuma
konsumieren und da habe ich einfach auch
immer nur sachen auf vorrat die ich
wirklich benutzt und das ist glaube ich
so das wichtigste was man sich da
überlegen muss hier unten sind eher so
meine back vorräte bisschen getrennt
also räumlich getrennt weil gewürze wenn
ich jetzt da curry drin haben und hier
unten so was wie backpulver dann nimmt
es gerne mal den geruch an also räumlich
trennen voneinander und hier habe ich
dann so meine orangen passten backpulver
natron alles schön in schubladen
darunter ok ok - einst so zu sagen ich
mag halt echt viel und die abstellt kann
man hier ist wirklich ziemlich groß man
könnte hier noch einiges mehr verstehen
aber ich hab halt viele back vorräte
ich habe halt immer so 10 km
und ja ja ihr kennt meinen back
verbrauch es sieht jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen ab noch mal aus ich hab jetzt
auch unterteilt in mandeln und
haselnüsse usw
daher
und auch bei zucker ist so zucker läuft
im prinzip nie abzocker ist ja auch ein
konservierungsmittel für marmeladen zum
beispiel und für andere lebensmittel und
da könnt ihr euch wirklich auch einen
gesunden vorrat an zucker am anlegen und
ja da wird nicht schlecht
[Musik]
mein obst habe ich immer hier
denn der ist total gern viel obst und
gemüse und dann können sie eben direkt
dran gehen ohne dass an den kühlschrank
ran müssen
so sieht es dann hier auswärts auf und
eingeräumt ist und ich liebe meine
arbeitsplatte hier
denn ich arbeite hier auch wirklich ganz
schön viel und zwar habe ich meinen
alles schneider und meint der automaten
und wenn ich dann obst und gemüse oder
auch kräuter dürren will kann ich das
eben schön hier machen hier zu bereiten
und hier dann direktorin und wie ich
meine lebensmittel einlege oder dürre
trockene und haltbar machen könnt ihr
übrigens in meinem video nachschauen da
habe ich bereits 1 gemacht und da
bespreche ich genau diese sachen wie
schneiden trocknen dürren einlegen
säuern salzen zu können und da können
dann mal schauen wie man lebensmittel
länger haltbar macht also wie gesagt
rechts hier habe ich meine herzhaften
lebensmittel wie reis nudeln oder
backpapier vorräte hier links habe ich
eher so meine backzutaten und gewürze
und hier in der mitte war noch platz und
das ist auch mein lieblings schrank
eigentlich hier drinnen
es ist platz für pfandflaschen denn wir
haben nicht nur glasflaschen in kisten
die man super verstauen kann sondern man
hat halt schon immer mal auch eine dose
oder ein anderes getränk und weiß dann
immer nicht wohin mit dem fand ich weiß
noch bei meiner mutter war es immer so
sehr hat es an dann so eine tüte an der
wand wo sie alles reingestopft hat aber
ich habe gesagt ich will diese
plastikflaschen und diese pet-flaschen
nicht sehen also haben wir hier einfach
so zwei säcke drin einen für pt als
pfandflaschen oder auch warnt gläser wie
joghurt leser zum beispiel und die
andere diesen anderen beutel benutzen
wir einfach für glas was eben weg kommt
wie heißt das glas also ein weg leser
genau meinte ich doch mehr weh kein weg
danke in zwei wörtern erklärt und sally
hat drei stunden dafür gebraucht ich
sagte meinen kopf ist max 11 richtig
much heute also ich mach's nochmal
j&j würde das jetzt so erklären hier
habe ich eine schublade unterm einer
arbeitsplatte und ein sack ist hier für
mehrwegflaschen und einsatz für
einwegflaschen in der kürze liegt die
würze ja aber ich hab was vergessen und
zwar kann steht diese decke einfach dann
mitnehmen da sein pfand weg bringen das
geld einkassieren etwas neues davon
kaufen und später wieder hier einsetzen
und das ist ja der trick daran dass du
praktisch keine extra tüten dafür
brauchst und wirklich alles schön sauber
verstaut ist und die taschen die kann
man auch auswaschen also falls wirklich
mal was ausläuft und es hier drin dann
riecht dann wäscht man sie einfach kurz
auslöste trocknen und setzte wieder ein
und was ich euch hier zeigen muss und
das ist wirklich der oberhammer worauf
verkauft immer seine idee aber es war
meine idee denn ich habe hier den
direkten durchgang zur kirche
und dann ist es so als wird nur aus dem
küchenschrank rauskommen cool oder und
einst war hier nämlich sozusagen eine
ganz normale tür und ich hab dann
unserem küchenbauer also da claudia
gesagt ich hätte es gern als küchen
front und so ist die tür einfach
wunderbar versteckt man sieht sie nicht
sie stört nicht und ich habe es ihr
trotzdem da war meine idee morath nicht
deine er verkauft sie bald seine aber
kommt beginnt mitarbeiter und dann habe
ich im prinzip einfach noch links vom
fenster nur noch diese schränke nur noch
ist gut denn da habe ich auch noch mal
so acht quadratmeter kubikmeter raum
naja ich hier habe ich es war der morath
hast du ja nicht stören spielt einfach
weiter ich freue mich zu sagen aufmacht
und kann zu erwischen
ja ich will vielleicht waren sind
und hier habe ich meine mama laden drin
oder sowas wie oh mein gott
es war doch noch nicht leer ich verstehe
das ja es gibt noch marmeladen habe ich
hier drinnen dann habe ich hier vorräte
für kinder snacks also wenn man immer
mal so so keine frucht quetsch ist da
hier unten wäre eigentlich platz für
abfall aber ich habe alles sagt ich bin
ich hier im raum kein waschbecken haben
und auch keinen mülleimer haben denn
alles was man hat muss man halt auch
pflegen das heißt für mich ich müsste
noch im waschbecken putzen jeden tag und
da habe ich keine lust drauf also haben
hier kein waschbecken und vor allem ich
ja der weg zur küche wirklich also immer
mal ehrlich sind zwei meter und einmal
wollte ich hier auch nicht denn ich
trage einfach alles dann in die küche
und hier habe ich einfach alle typen die
sich so in unserem leben angesammelt
haben ich kann seine tüten box hat jeder
und ich habe ich auch einfach nur mal so
trockene vorräte er so müsli und
frühstück sachen die sind dann hier
da kommen auch die kids ganz gut dran so
wissel am rand und getrocknetes obst da
unten es ist eigentlich ein blöder platz
dafür denn ella gerne mal dran wenn sie
daran denkt da sind so was wie
marshmallows oder pc drops oder kekse
die ich zum backen benutze muss ich
vielleicht dem platz noch mal ändern
denn die kleine die findet echt alles
hier haben wir noch so täterin herzhafte
snacks und dann ganz wichtig süße snacks
hier oben damit sie da eben nicht so oft
da rangehen
da komme ich dann wirklich gut dran der
morath leider auch immer so gut aber so
ist es halt
und weil wir wirklich gar keinen platz
verschenkt haben sind sogar hier aus und
es sind keine blenden sondern es sind
auch schränke und da ist vor
guck mal rein ich habe meine kerzen
verstaut farblich sortiert
natürlich schön schön oder ja und
fenster offen ist noch im schrank
oh mein gott sind die bvb team von murat
jetzt weiß ich wieder warum ich sie
daran was habe ich hier noch mario
vorräte und kekse die ich zum backen
benutze und damit sie keine auf ist habe
ich sehr hoch denn da kommen nur ich
[Musik]
also das war jetzt so unser
hauswirtschaftsraum was ich glaube ich
noch erzählen
bis bald fertig hol dir einfach studie
ist immer da das macht was ich hab doch
extra hier die sachen cook beschriftet
outdoor das muss hierbleiben spüle ist
eine reihe hier so und dann ist hier
eine reihe boden reiniger ethischen
akkurat kannst du das später bitter
wieder sortieren
wenig später sie mache ich muss auch
wohl okay nichts zu suchen
nächster versuch also das was unser
hauswirtschaftsraum eine würdig den
hauswirtschaftsraum sozusagen und was
wirklich ganz ganz wichtig ist und es
ist glaube ich die wichtigste info alles
was ihr hoch oben lagern müsst sind so
dinge wie medikamente alkohol
süßigkeiten und putzmittel da sollten
nämlich kleine kinder und kleine männer
nicht drankommen
und was noch zum thema
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
also kaufte teure lebensmittel wirklich
immer mitbedacht kauft nur auf vorrat
ein was ihr auch wirklich oft verwendet
wenn ihr lebensmittel frisch ausprobiert
und einfach mal was testen wollt aber
nur ein päckchen kaufen und schauen ob
es euch eben gut schmeckt und wirklich
nur das lagern was häufig verzehrt wird
und dann gibt es eben lebensmittel die
trotz des mindesthaltbarkeitsdatums was
vielleicht abgelaufen ist trotzdem noch
haltbar sind
da kann ich euch so eine kleine
übersicht geben ihr könnt ich im prinzip
merken dass abgepacktes brot bis zu acht
wochen haltbar ist säften in
pet-flaschen ungefähr zwei bis drei
monate
selbst im tetrapack aber bis zu sechs
monate und säfte im glas sogar bis zu
einem jahr haltbar
getrocknete kräuter und gewürze sind
vier bis fünf jahre haltbar
nudeln ohne ei sogar mehrere jahre als
wenn es um vollkorn oder naturreis ist
bis zu einem jahr und wenn es ein
geschälter weiterreise ist sogar bis zu
zwei jahre
weil einfach das feld schon entzogen
wurde mehl könnt ihr bis ein jahr nach
dem mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum benutzen
und milchprodukte die in den kühlschrank
gehören die sind auch mehrere wochen
noch haltbar und pastors
milchprodukte wie pasteurisierte milch
die es auch mehrere monate nach
haltbarkeitsdatum noch haltbar
alles in allem muss man aber sozusagen
das man einfach nach der nase gehen muss
und auch nach der optik das heißt wenn
ihr irgendwo auf irgendeinem
lebensmittel schon schimmelsporen sieht
sofort wegschmeißen denn der schimmel
der verbreitet sich auch unsichtbar
gerade bei frischen lebensmitteln aus
dem kühlschrank ist es wirklich super
wichtig und natürlich nach der nase
gehen also wenn ihr auch an der milch
riecht und die riecht einfach schon
sauer nicht mehr benutzen
es kann ja auch sein dass mal was
schlecht geworden ist obwohl es noch
haltbar ist deswegen immer nach dem
closing ging ja und das war es unsere
rumturnen ich hoffe ihr konntet euch ein
paar tipps und tricks abholen
das war wirklich auch ein video wonach
ganz ganz viele menschen gefragt haben
ich hoffe ich konnte alle eure fragen
beantworten falls nicht dann schreibt
sie mir gerne und ich freue mich auf
euer feedback und wir sehen uns wieder
das nächste mal
ich wollte eigentlich noch sagen
ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen soll ich
habe auch einen raum mit einbauschränken
also ich hab mir das video nicht
angeschaut ob ich weiß das jemand ganz
viele einbauschränke hatte zwei fragen
im video kommentiert wurde
hey ich habe jetzt auch einen raum mit
einbauschränken und ich nutze sie er hat
es verstanden also gerade auch jetzt
mehr annehme hin haben wir hier aus
pandemie mache ich ein paar grüße gehen
raus und die comedy aber immer wenn ich
jetzt von mir hören sich an den zaun
decken und dann naja egal